le procès villemin suite les audiences
étaient importantes aujourd'hui ce matin
les experts psychiatres ont tracé le
portrait psychologique de l'accusé jean
marie villemin
et cet après midi christine villemin
témoigné dominique verdeilhan compte
rendu d'audience la justice n'était pas
la seule à attendre ce rendez vous pour
jean marie villemin quand il quitte la
prison de dijon à 7h30
il sait que ce sont des retrouvailles
qui s'annoncent depuis trois jours les
règles de la cour d'assises ont séparés
de force
la presse aussi l'attend comme si depuis
mardi son image était devenu rare
entouré de ses quatre avocats
escorté par les photographes protégé par
les policiers christine villemin fait
son entrée au palais de justice
la dernière fois l'ailier vous du crm
sont non lieu aujourd'hui innocenté
elle vole au secours de son époux il est
neuf ans
ce n'est que cette heure plus tard
qu'elle pénètre dans la cour d'assises
je voudrais tellement trouver les mots
justes pour dire la souffrance qu'on a
vécu on a essayé de comprendre ce qu'on
avait fait pour qu'on nous prenne notre
enfant quand j'ai été inculpé j'étais
anéantie on voulait nous séparer mais
plus on prenait des coups plus notre
amour grandissait avec jean-marie j'ai
compris ce que voulait dire les mots
aimer et être aimé les retrouvailles ont
eu lieu mais pas la confrontation
celle avec marie-ange et muriel absente
venir à dijon durant cinq semaines coûte
cher 10 leurs avocats choix délibéré ou
hasard ainsi n'ont elles pas assisté
aujourd'hui à cette déclaration d'amour
jean marie villemin n'avait d'yeux que
pour christine et même la vitre
pare-balles du box n'est pas parvenu à
les séparer